everyone who works at 30 rock I asked
him this question Tracy Morgan what is
it like to work with that man
he says he's an amazing president he's a
man-child just like us the most generous
man is a man boy okay no in what way
tell us he just he's very sweet and very
sensitive like my image of Tracy
is always the first season and he had
this tape he had and he would lay in his
room like like he would lay on the couch
he was really tired he had to get hit
probably had a late night and he was
waiting for them to bring him in to do
to do makeup and he'd be laying on the
couch completely zonked out at six seven
o'clock in the morning 6:30 anymore and
he's watching old like kinescope
transfers or some like ancient media of
the of like Jackson five specials from
like the 70s so literally it's like
seven o'clock in the morning Michael
Jackson sitting there
he's watching yes Sam over and over
Tracy's displaying their juggling and I
walk and I go how you doing man you all
right he's like Michael Mayer he was
powerful
Oh Maj - Michael Jackson like at seven
o'clock you know he had like a little
moment with masters desert he does his
lines he doesn't know his lines
everyone says that even things to
memorize them posted Claire cop birth
weight is our script supervisor and
Claire's right there and Tracey's on and
you said go yeah so what do you I want
you and Claire will go he'll go I got it
[Laughter]
doesn't have it where's like I'll meet
you at three o'clock I had it three
o'clock